Queen Elsa and Princess Anna have
changed tremendously since we first saw
them in 2013's frozen they've matured a
lot over the years and they have the
Wardrobe to prove it heck even Kristoff
got an upgrade
keep watching to see Elsa on it and
Christoph's new official character looks
[Music]
Princess Anna Anna is by far one of the
most popular Disney Princesses out of
the bunch
she's fun down-to-earth and always ready
for an adventure if only her outfits
could resonate with her unpredictable
personality in frozen honest style is
very classic and pristine she's seen
wearing a green ball gown that
accentuates her waist her bodice is made
out of a forest green felt and her hair
is done up in a braided updo this is the
gown on a where's terror sisters
coronation but on us soon changes into
something more appropriate
after embarking on a winner's excursion
the princess of arendelle changes into a
blue floor-length dress which is
accompanied by a fuchsia cloak and baby
blue mittens her classy updo is no more
she's traded it in for some braided
pigtails on us typically seen wearing
greens and neutrals so we weren't
surprised to see her come back to her
roots by the end of the movie her last
outfit is totally adorable she's wearing
an off white long-sleeved button-up
underneath a green floor-length dress
she's still rocking her braids which
have become her signature hairstyle in
2017 Disney released the short film
Olaf's frozen adventure and it's here
that we got to see on an else's holiday
outfits but we'll get to Elsa later
let's focus on Anna for now in this
adorable mini movie we see Anna wearing
the color blue once again she's wearing
a crop blazer with a high neck in a long
blue dress her sleeves are embroidered
with white designs giving her otherwise
clean outfit some extra flare on his
hair is done up coronation style but
this time she's got some feathers in her
hair which totally resonate with her
free as a bird personality fans have
been impatiently waiting for frozen -
ever since its epic trailer was released
in February 2019 if there's one thing
fans couldn't help but notice it's how
mature Princess Anna has become she's
put her braided pigtails in the past and
let her hair down for like the first
time ever the top portion is clipped
allowing her banks to frame her face at
the beginning of the trailer we see on a
run out onto her balcony she's wearing
green pajamas which is no big surprise
considering green seems to be her
signature color however on a ditches the
color green wants a new adventure
presents itself much like in frozen
Ana's wearing an off purple cloak
knee-high black boots and a dark purple
dress her new look is a lot darker than
usual does this mean that honest sweet
and jovial personality is going to be
more refined come the sequel we'll have
to wait to find out in the meantime
let's find out just how much Ana's
boyfriend Christoph has changed since we
first laid eyes on him Christoph when we
first meet Christoph he's covered in
snow from head to toe and he's not very
happy about it to say the least
Kurt behind you oh right Christoph is an
ice Harvester by trade so an eternal
winner isn't something that's good for
business your stuff usually wears a
tooth we can still see his shaggy blond
hair peeking out from underneath it
being an ice Harvester means that you
need to be prepared for tough weather
conditions so Christophe is suited up
and ready for action in frozen
Christophe is typically seen wearing his
Brown Pelt coat huge gloves and big
winter boots he's wearing a fuchsia sash
around his waist and the collar of his
coat is lined with the same fabric
he's a low-key matching with honor my
sister you're gonna kill yourself at the
end of the movie when L says winter
spell has been undone we get to see
Christoph in his summer clothes his hat
is nowhere to be found
and his blown locks are doing that
adorable flippy thing he's wearing a
long-sleeve blue shirt with a dark vest
he looks super put together but we
wouldn't expect anything less from
arendelle's official ice master and
deliverer in Olaf's roads an adventure
we see Christoph sporting a brand new
look however his winter outfit is
somewhat similar to the summer outfit we
saw him wearing at the end of frozen
looks like Christoph likes to keep
things simple and functional he's
wearing a light blue long sleeved
undershirts opt with a navy blue vest
the vest has a high collar in a string
of fashionable buttons although his
outfit may be basic you can tell it was
made with quality materials
and since Kristoff and Anna are totally
matching we can only assume that
Christoph's wardrobe received a royal
makeover by the end of the short film
Kristoff is back to wearing his original
ice harvesting outfit some things never
change
and apparently Kristoff style is one of
them although Christoph's classic outfit
didn't receive a total makeover he's
sporting some fresh new clothes in
frozen to whoever's designing his
wardrobe knows that he's a simple man
who likes things to be practical and
warm
Christoph's new look has been revamped
his boots are more elf like while his
sleeves seemed to be made out of warm
fur his sash is no longer fuchsia it's a
dark tan all-in-all Christoph's clothing
is now made with rich materials and it
shows but not much else has changed much
like onna Chris tops color scheme was
taken down a few notches giving him more
of a somber look Queen Elsa
Queen Elsa is typically showcased
wearing the color blue
she is the ice queen after all oddly
enough during her coronation she's
showcased wearing a tulle gown with a
fuchsia cloak her hair is done up in a
braided updo just like Ana's after the
coronation takes a turn for the worst
Queen Elsa flees arendelle and gives
herself a well-deserved makeover she
treats in her teal gown for a blue and
sparkly snowflake inspired dress
it's simply breathtaking she also and
does her updo and lets her braid hang
freely what an epic transformation in
Olaf's frozen adventure Queen Elsa's
outfit isn't too different than the one
showcased in the original film however
this time her gown is midnight blue her
long train is dusted with silvery
snowflakes and her collar is lined with
white fur Elsa's still rocking her
classic braid we can't get over how
majestic the queen of arendelle looks in
this outfit our surprise holiday party
doesn't start until after the Yule bell
ring Elsa's newest look is one for the
books it's super classy and weightless
making it the perfect choice for a royal
adventure else's wearing a light blue
overcoat which is embroidered with
silver designs she's also wearing a
sparkly white gown underneath her coat
Elsa's hair hasn't changed one bit
but her shoe sure have we mean check out
those sparkly knee-high boots they're to
die for so whose new look do you prefer
Elsa honor
Christoph's let us know in the comment
section below and while you're at it
tell us who your favorite frozen
character is and that's a wrap give this
video a big thumbs up if you're excited
for frozen - to hit the theatres and as
usual don't forget to leave a comment
and subscribe to the scenes for the
latest Disney news thanks for watching
we'll see you next time
[Music]